[Music]
the world of spirit breaks up into two
the first is the world of reality or of
its self alienation but the other is
that which spirit rising above the first
constructs for itself in the ether of
pure consciousness the second world
standing in antithesis to that
alienation is for that very reason not
free from it on the contrary it is
really only the other form of that
alienation which consists precisely in
being conscious of two different worlds
and which embraces both therefore it is
not the self consciousness of absolute
being as it is in and for itself not
religion that is here dealt with but
faith insofar as this is a flight from
the real world and thus is not in and
for itself this flight from the realm of
the present is therefore in its own self
dual natured pure consciousness is the
element into which spirit raises itself
but it is not only the element of faith
but equally of the notion consequently
both together make their appearance at
the same time of the former comes into
consideration only in its antithesis to
the latter
paragraph 487 provides us with the only
introduction to this this entire
subsection that Hegel is entitling the
world of self alienated spirit you know
and unlike many of the other subsections
where we've got an introduction usually
it's two or three paragraphs sometimes
even more before Hegel launches into it
and this one is a little bit of a
strange paragraph he's talking a lot
about faith but that's not all that's
going to be happening in this section as
a matter of fact the very first part of
a culture in its realm of actuality is
not going to be talking about faith at
all that's that's portion a and then
portion B is going to talk about faith
and insight and that's really faith and
the notion or the McGrath the concept so
what is going on in this paragraph well
we'll talk about that specifically and
we'll also talk about what's what's not
going on in the paragraph and what Hegel
is just sort of hinting at or passing
over that we we want to keep in mind as
we're moving into this this next section
which is not going to be the section of
faith it's going to be the section of
culture and it's realm of actuality or a
reality
vier claim type so let's start with the
text Hegel tells us that the world of
this spirit breaks up into two and there
Miller is translating a little bit
loosely Hegel uses this Godot pulta
right you know Godot Boone or yeah dopes
them to double itself - and this is
something that we've seen happen it at
multiple points you know we can talk
about the world doubling itself we can
talk about self-consciousness doubling
itself introducing ambiguities we've
seen a lot of different dynamics with
this over the course of the path that
we've traversed so far so the world of
spirits as we
you've come to this point now he says
doubles itself it splits itself into two
and he's going to chart out really what
is happening I would say from the
perspective of the phenomenologist not
saying that this is what each
consciousness that is going through
these different stages or shapes of
consciousness is actually encountering
or you know taking on the form of
because what's happening here he talks
about the first world as one involving
and alienation from self right a you
know becoming other a becoming alien a
never really being what it is in
relation to itself but then he talks
about another alienation that is
happening in the second world and this
alienation happens through and
antithesis or opposition to the first
world that also encompasses the second
world so we're talking about a pretty
developed and complex shape of
consciousness at this point a complex
motive of spirit so let's follow this
out he says the first world that the
world of spirit splits into is the world
of reality of veer Clea kite but then he
says war of its self alienation and he's
talking about it there as if for it to
be the world of reality is necessarily
at this point for it to be the world of
its self alienation for it to be real
means to be alienated now that certainly
wasn't the case in some of the earlier
sections so that that is an achievement
that we've gotten to and for Hegel a
good portion of culture in in the Middle
Ages in
modernity is this this state of being in
a kind of alienation we saw that he also
has you know the the the Greek
city-state the the Roman Republic even
you know a lot of things going on in in
small medieval societies or those that
that last into modernity where the
individual knows where he or she belongs
the ethical substance is something you
might say kind of constrained but as it
grows larger which is what happens
precisely through legal right the
section that we just passed through and
also much earlier in the passages where
we had getting beyond the master-slave
dialectic you know stoicism skepticism
unhappy consciousness what was going on
in the reason section once we started
turning to practical reason we have an
alienation from from self as being
integral to self consciousness to
rational self consciousness to self
consciousness as spirit so the person is
never truly at home anymore never
entirely happy with or assured of who he
or she is in relation to you know
whatever we want to call it the ethical
the project that which provides meaning
so now Hegel immediately moves from that
which is again that's what we're going
to be looking at in the next section so
I do want to come back to that Hegel is
going to move away from that and he's
going to talk about a second world says
the other world
is that it that which spirit rising
above the first notice that he's going
to use two words to describe this so
actually I should I should put both of
these on the board there's a flight but
it's also a rising right and that
depends on how we look at it it's rising
above this world of alienation or it's
fleeing from this world of alienation so
he says the second rising above the
first constructs it's for itself
in the ether of pure consciousness so
what's going on here consciousness as
determinate consciousness not pure self
consciousness is constructing a world
for itself it's projecting into a beyond
it is you might say creating its own
mythology or its own hagiography or its
own imagery in this this other world
which is its own product does this start
to sound remotely like what was going on
in the unhappy consciousness it
certainly should it should be recalling
all of those movements to you right now
so Hegel here is talking about this
being something that is constructed in
the ether the you know other elements of
pure self consciousness that's why it's
available as a possibility we get away
from the determinacy of the mucky messy
alienated world that we belong to the
world of actuality where nothing turns
out really quite to be as it should be
or what it originally seemed to be and
we construct a world beyond it now does
this resolve anything
no why not says this second world stands
in antithesis to that alienation so what
does that mean it stands an antithesis
to that alienation it seems to be
opposed to it it is something going
beyond it perhaps even transcending it
right that's why you do it in the first
place but does it get away from the
alienation no it intensifies it this is
where we get to something very
interesting so he says this second world
standing in antithesis to that
alienation is for that very reason not
free from the alienation it's
not just that it has sort of dirty you
know hands because of its origin in the
alienation that it was fleeing and it
can never really get away from it
you know it's carrying a primal guilt or
whatever else you want to say no it
still exists in relation to it that
world of that world of culture as
alienation has not been completely left
behind and there's still sort of a you
know inkling in one's mind when you're
dwelling in this world of faith that
well this isn't really the full story
it's sort of like you know and this was
going to be a bit of a a stretch in
terms of metaphor if you've ever read
decart's meditations when you read
meditation one there's this really
interesting passage at the end of
meditation one where Descartes but he's
bringing up this you know methodological
doubt and I can doubt this and I can
doubt that and he says you know perhaps
I can't really be certain of anything
and he talks about this this image of a
slave who realizes that he is dreaming
actually this maybe at the beginning of
meditation - I may be misremembering
remembering but here's here's the the
metaphor it's a slave who realizes that
he's being presented with dreams and he
once he begins to suspect that he's torn
because he doesn't want to wake up why
doesn't he want to wake up because he
knows that the reality that he's waking
to is a much less pleasant place to be
it could be a reality of alienation
right and so in this frame we can think
of ourselves if we're following along is
consciousness as the person of faith the
the person of faith has everything
resolved but they don't really have
everything resolved because the world
remains what it is and they're rooting
in that first world remains there as
well so he says on the contrary the
second world is really only the other
form of that alien
which consists precisely in being
conscious of two different worlds and
which embraces both so we have here a
kind of inability to to move past the
antithesis here would be a place I
suppose where you know those who are
enamored of you know relying over much
on the thesis antithesis synthesis
triatic movement which Hegel does use at
some points but doesn't use at many
other points particularly in the
phenomenology might say that the
synthesis is being blocked there is no
possibility of synthesis at this point
there is only the consciousness of
opposition of antithesis of things being
you know resistant to each other and the
second world exists when self
consciousness is being honest with
itself in relation to this already
alienated world so the alienation just
becomes even more intensified in this
this world of faith so what does Hegel
tell us here he says it's not self
consciousness of absolute being as it is
in and for itself that that we find in
faith it is I'm going to repeat that it
is not the self consciousness of
absolute being as it is in and for
itself that is actually going to be what
he calls religion and that's a much
later section a section which is the the
very last one in the work and which as
he says in the beginning of that is
tying together all of these previous
four movements of consciousness self
consciousness reason and spirit that is
something different than just what you
know Hegel calls faith or a globine
there's a a progression there so what is
happening with faith is not indeed
grasping absolute being in and for
itself although there is a desire to do
so there is an attempt to get that far
but that's not what's actually happening
here so then what is happening here well
let's read on a little bit more he says
this flight from the present is
therefore in itself dual natured so not
only do we have a doubling here we have
a doubling here as well an ambiguity
that is introduced right this is doubled
in two to two worlds which they're then
related to each other in complex ways
what is the ambiguity over on the other
side well this is where Hegel is going
to talk about what we're going to call
insight which is a form of the notion or
the concept which is operating in pure
consciousness as is faith and that's
what the entire second section of this
this portion of the text is going to be
about so he says pure consciousness is
the element into which Spirit raises
itself but when it does that it's not
just going to find faith there like it
says it's not only the element of faith
but also equally of the notion so he
says both together make their appearance
at the same time and the former that
what is the former their the faith comes
into consideration only in its
antithesis to the latter so in a certain
sense you know it again I've talked a
little bit before about our
characterization that we see in a lot of
you know historians of the Middle Ages
as the age of faith but the Middle Ages
is also the age of insight as well and
insight here is something that doesn't
necessarily secularize but which
certainly does go beyond the ways in
which faith is being articulated and and
sort of leaving that behind and then
secularization will come in afterwards
and this is a struggle even in the
middle of the age of faith all you have
to do is read some medieval history to
know that that's the case
and you know even the
best would be reading monastic history
because you will see this struggle at
the heart of each you know monastic
order and in the monasteries themselves
now that's a bit of a digression part of
what I want to come back to is the fact
that in this passage Hegel talks a lot
about this and the fact that you know
you've got a complex alienation here
that it's going to be the realm both of
faith and of the notion or of insight
but he does not talk a lot about this
and that should be curious to you
because you know this is an introductory
paragraph why is he not talking about
the big themes that are gonna be coming
up in these these paragraphs coming
immediately after this and what are
these themes so we should talk about
that a bit he's going to be you know
going into some discussion about the
elements and how we get from you know
you know what what's going on within the
realm of legal right and then he's gonna
talk about a struggle between good and
bad and this is going to take on a
different form now what is he going to
talk about these as instantiating
themselves with they're gonna take
there's going to be a dialectic here of
what Hegel calls wealth and state power
so two different things that appear to
be good for for human beings are playing
themselves out as the ways in which
things determine themselves neither of
them totally overcomes this alienation
from self but both of us both of them do
drive us further and he's going to talk
about the noble and the ignoble
consciousness and we're gonna have this
very interesting interplay going on
between it and that is part of the
development of spirit so why is he not
giving us even a glimpse of this here
that's that's a question that I think is
is worth asking ourselves
and I don't actually have an answer for
it at this point I may when we go
through that that section but it's worth
thinking a little bit about where we're
going we're gonna have to first talk a
lot about this world and then we can
jump into this cool stuff over here
about the second world the alienation
and the antithesis that is taking place
between them and this then transition to
faith and the notion
you